AJ gre's back in the lineup he'll play with Sher
goich and derer with rosich got with an injury and
the fourth line or third line depending on how you
look at is Du between hunts and Coronado as this
one is underway glad to have you with us right now
though it's the blues with a puck in the offensive
zone pass to the slot deflect It Away by colan
he opened the scoring against the Rangers the
other night a minute 15 seconds in but here's a
great chance early for the blues and Thomas can't
believe it as he's stopped by Mar from Point Blank
Range going to see Kyu he's going to spot Thomas
in behind the Flames defense and beautiful save by
marrom and then a two-on-one just seconds later by
the Flames generated by m japani chipping it to
Coleman but Ley does a pretty good job here but
it does come to weager and H for with his throws
a pass to the slot broken up by the flames and
they'll bring it out two on one Coleman has
weer with him here's colan trying to get it
across finally does and the Pu trickles wide hoer
may have gotten the piece of it chopped away from
him Coleman flips it up the boards backing gets
it out good pass to mapani in on Paro he'll turn
nice play Coleman stopped by huler terrific set up
and Hofer makes his best save of the game so far
on Blake Coleman is two under career point almost
2011 right there still goalless in Calgary hubero
stands his ground at the point Jonathan hubero
with the pass to cadri huberto he surveys down
low cadri in front for L fired to wide little
Tic-Tac toe passing there but lenol just missed
as he tried to go blocker side wager back over
the line he skate it in deep and play the puck
all the way around for nzm cadri cadry's pass
back intercepted by sunquist as C and breaking
through the middle short handed C right in scores
casber C it shorthanded makes it one- nothing St
Louis sunquist is a really good penalty killer
he's a real good effective player there's a turn
over sunqu spots kaing watch that beautiful little
saucer pass and kaan goes from his backand great
here quickly to his forehand and elevates that is
a beautifully played shot by the forward on the
St L lifts it to the line no further settled
down by lety feeds it ahead here's Hayes in
on the right side Gilbert sticks to him Hayes
forced in deep Banks it back to Ley he takes a
shot they score tipped in from what off something
might have been a flame but either way it's two
nothing St Louis and we're going to see a great
example of this just go work down low PH does a
great job going to get it back to Ley and watch
a traffic in front there's two guys there there's
neighbors and torup chenko I believe somebody
does deflect it rick oh I I believe it's torko
it went off Sor off's leg at the end but it looked
like it changed Direction I'm not sure I thought
maybe Neighbors in front but der and Sharon goich
late in the first period shot by weager goes off
the leg of derer hubero puts the pass to Sharon
goich with a shot rebound bounces in front batted
out by Hanahan chipped it across broken up by Ley
and now it's fed through Center here's kyou right
in stopped by markstrom rebound Thomas stopped
by markstrom two terrific chances there for the
blues and a couple of big saves for Jacob arrom
find kyou right through the middle there's a gap
he's in behind the defenseman watch just left
pad save but maybe more importantly the rebound
save off Thomas he keeps it at two nothing that
would have been a real pull to dig yourself out
of scramble drop flames on it tanip brings
the puck out as Coleman and mapani with him
on the rush tanip tries a shot turned away
by hoper steers the puck to the board Shen
is there flips it behind the net long pass
by crew ticked in by bich and arrom will
stop that down low as we hit the final
minute of play the first Blake Coleman
Chris tanv now some room down the right side
makes a pass to back threw it in front chip
wide of the goal by monani might have gone off
a stick back in the crease and it's gloved by
hord bman Coleman M japon to start against
the Thomas line with sad and kyou was period
two was underway Flames control off the face off
weager pass to mapani in needs it down low Pass
High slop with sage Kyu pavich takes a look
feeds it over kyou pavich kyou stopped by Mar
the terrific save off kyou from the circle
fired back over Thomas able to pick it up
marrom save a number of times kyou wide open
net look at the effort by markstrom hard from
his right to his left glove save spectacular
Again by Jacob marrom nice and simple here's
zorov Coronado now takes a look shoots blocker
save rebound too far for hubero to settle it
down and now an odd man Rush the other way
sunquist Toreno in front it's the Traer L SC
by Marr got the left p on that one as Sharon
gold with it tan over to Sharon it's falling
up stop by Haler pass was deflected penalty
coming up to the Blues watch this burst the
speed by Chris tanv that's crew and he can't
catch him in fact tanv gets away from him then
in comes do derer that's a great save by Hofer
good play by fault to break that up but that's
a really big save and then the blues called for
career put it in front it's picked off by Hayes
and fed ahead to Samy Blake sunqu racing onto it
backhand stop by Marr rebound picked up by Walker
do backin out there to face off against Thomas
Flames win it hanen with control on japani
pressured at the line paro's able to fire it
around the boards marstrom puts it back around
the glass Ricochet to the point Thomas kept it
alive sod goes to the goal Thomas with a shot
and a glove save by markr and Robert forzo able
to get it out to bunich cross eyes for Shen in a
room now the wing and a shot off the post snuck
that one pass marks froma couldn't beat the goal
post he on his knees and spot Shen and Shen
just Rings Rings this short side retreats to
the boards Coronado sharing all that's with
a shot turned away by huler good look there
for jagor Sharon goic on a setup for Coronado
and H forced to make a good save and that one
good drawway tan keeps the play going as icing
his wave takes off through Center checked at
the line by Butch navage works it back the
other way with neighbors neighbors put him
towards the goal off the tow Marsh might have
been going wide back to the point now weager
Hanahan rer deflected wide by Leno picked up by
hubero on the far side weager shoots and that
the flex wide Puck Ricochet to sunst for the
and he scores posted in from his own end Oscar
sunquist gets his first of the Season without
any hesitation he rifles that down the ice he's
been a nice Edition this is second Tour of Duty
with St Louis Coleman down the wing on japani and
back with him here's back shoot stop stopped
the rebound to couple of big saves there by
Hur as the the Flames come close to getting
on the board hanifan back near his own Blue
Line Coleman puts that one in wide of the
goal another stop by hoper with the left
pad 20 seconds left Hanan bounced in front
and shot wide by hunt H for sto the second
chance that came off the end boards that
kind of a knife for the Flames offense ly
and Puck around the boards weer keeps it
alive and that'll do it 25 saves for his
first career shut out as Joel hord back stops
the blues to a three- Nothing winning Calgary